[Applause]
don't be a little bitch man hey
everybody welcome to every damn day
today we're gonna be doing learning and
burning it's the holiday edition this is
the segment where I eat something really
hot and then I try to learn something
teaching me as always is real life PhD
dr. naydern that's me Ryan like you said
it's a special holiday edition to open
that up to find out the bird I heard
rumor it's gonna be like that hot
chocolate or like some kind of chocolate
that's hot or something fun like that so
I'll go ahead and fire away go away go
okay okay
this is like a powder or something the
Trinidad scorpion is today's burn
Scoville rating of 1.4 million this is
for real the spiciest thing we've done
this is the first time I've been
legitimately worried these are from why
Chinatown
they don't have regulations down there
it's Chinatown baby as always on milk
duty is Hana so how this is gonna work
in just a moment Ryan is gonna eat one
of these peppers I will then hand him a
card where he's gonna have to learn
about something today so he'll be
reading from that card learning new
information I will then quiz Ryan on
that info and only one he has correctly
answered a series of questions will he
be given the sweet relief of that milk
Hannah will hand it to him we've got a
vomit bucket why are you frowning man
this is your idea no no I thought it was
like a chocolate thing in his holiday I
had one big me deed scorpion pepper they
might
so if you ask for a certain pair of
shoes and the either one color are gonna
be pissed didn't get exactly what you
want Santa wasn't the perfect guy to you
and now you're angry perfect guy okay do
you guys ever forget what you're doing
okay okay
sucks dude butthole smell I got two dogs
maybe I don't care
I'm sorry saying there's not a perfect
guy stupid twin power stance are you
ready to kick him away it's seriously
the most horrific thing I think yeah
we're a little bit even hold it I'm
scared just do it you little yeah you
can say we say a little bit yeah almost
a hundred episodes in you don't know if
we can say little bitch we say a little
bitch can you say a little bit just
trying to describe Ryan right Ryan is
being a little bitch can we say that
Brian's a little bitch should I do it
yeah just for shits
[Laughter]
Obie's mom oh oh don't be a little bitch
man we lost Anna
Trinidad's oh we have paper towels oh
wait you're reading the wrong thing I
can't read this I'll read it for us okay
listen you have to listen okay you start
to do it
Flannery O'Connor great knob that's what
it is learn Flannery O'Connor novelist
short story writer and essayist she
wrote two novels in 32 short story oh
girl that's sitting right she wrote in a
sardonic southern gothic style and
relied heavily on regional on it Ryan
sardonic style and support grotesque
and monstrous characters are often in
violent situations
she was Roman Catholic and frequently
examined questions of morality like a
good man is hard to find a short story
Nate Dern thanks Flannery O'Connor in
the acknowledgement section of his book
not quite a genius book starts now folks
they've turned favorite Flannery
O'Connor story is called Parkers back
that's right a sailor who has a bunch of
tattoos on his back okay Ryan first
question initial thoughts
yeah she's got like that's right Ryan
question - how do you spell Flannery oh
hey and then ery how many R's one that's
right what was Flannery's religion
Catholic a little more specific
Catholic what type of Catholic
well ruff roman-catholic is correct
Brian the Scoville scale rates spiciness
how many Scoville units would you guess
you're feeling in this scorpion pepper
right now million I'm over a million
that's right a little more specific over
a million I need a number 1.6 keep
guessing for that's right million next
next question Ryan like you Flannery was
born in the South although it did not
specify it but very small of the Midwest
Wow okay which state born in the south
oh can I guess it looks very gross in
there Georgia Georgia is right I did try
to listen what is Nate Burns favorite
Flannery O'Connor story Wow
you want to give a hint yeah I'm not
front but back okay and the first word
is room broom I got a blank my car back
to the okay free area with green back
Park let's switch it around park back we
better give it to that Oh
Parker's back can I hear you say that
Parker's back that's right that's my
favorite Oh Ryan you jumped the gun we
have one more question for you I'll
allow it
final question what is the point of art
to express and to connect that's right
applause oh don't do it
okay all right ease be a little bitch
all right Jordan
three two
[Laughter]
Jordan listen sensitive art a little bit
we've got a bad last thing that we've
got a shout out around here somewhere
Jordan can you do that any more milk I
think you ate in the room so haha so yes
I think from hotshot it is from
hyperopia whoa you think Hannah and
Jordan should date but also leave things
open for me to join hey let's do it to
be clear that was a youtube comment this
has been every damn day
[Applause]
[Music]
you